[Music]
uh let's speak to one of those defectors
kenny mccaskill he was the
snp mp for easter luthien and he joins
us now welcome to spectator tv kenny
mccaskill
thank you i was enjoying the discussion
on dundas
uh it was very interesting i agree the
the
author also mentions the hunterian
museum in
the university of glasgow which is one
of the finest university
museums uh in the united kingdom it now
has
what's called a curator of discomfort
i'm not quite sure what that is
but he's got one uh but i didn't get on
to that anyway back to
you and the elections
why have you left a party which was led
by
the most popular politician in scotland
to join one whose leader alex salmond
is as unpopular in scotland as boris
johnson
well i think this is the necessary
opportunity it's necessary because the
threat we're facing in terms of what
happens post-pandemic
in terms of increased austerity and
there's the opportunity there
by our independent super majority so
fundamentally it's about delivering an
independent super majority within the
scottish parliament
but equally be fair to say that there
had been issues within the snp
so i depart in reasonable terms because
i had many more good years and still
agree with much
but there were issues that took me to go
but fundamentally it's about what we can
do
and i think what we can say is that
we've already changed what was meant to
be a rather sleepy election
where independence was just simply going
to be rhetorical
and it was a question of would the snp
get a majority and who would come second
with independence now being front and
center of the debate
uh if you get this super majority you
you want a fast track referendum is that
right how quickly would you want a
second referendum
no what we're saying is it changes first
of all the whole nature of the debate
uh i know the snp position is the
thought that johnson would blink we
don't necessarily adhere to that
that this view that he'll change his
position on the section 30 orders that
technology is i think what we're seeking
to do is to ensure that after the 6th of
may
it's not a scottish government asking a
westminster prime minister
it's in fact the scottish parliament
representing scottish democracy
that is demanding the right for
self-determination that could be a
referendum if they're prepared to accede
to it there are other ways it can be
looked at in terms of
court actions international steps and
indeed just public
representation whether in demonstrations
as and when that's allowed
but how quickly if you get this super
majority how quickly would you like the
referendum
well we want to move towards scotland
getting the necessary powers as soon as
possible
whether that's by way of a referendum uh
that will have to be discussed because
so far that's not an option being
allowed and therefore
what other way could scotland get
independence other than a referendum
well you could have negotiations between
the parliaments ultimately you're
correct that
almost invariably they have to be put to
the people in a
in a referendum that happens it's
happened in slovakia it happened in
ireland over a century ago
but you could have the discussions about
where you're going uh rather than having
a
vote on the the the concept initially so
there's a whole array of opportunities
that would have to come about but if the
scottish parliament is representing the
democratic will of the scottish people
which is
for independence then i think that
changes the whole dynamic the same as
alba has changed the dynamic of the
electoral debate
but the scottish people on may are not
electing a parliament for independence
they're electing a parliament to run
their schools and their hospitals
and their transport that's uh if you
look at opinion polling
a second referendum comes way down the
list compared to hospitals and schools
the scottish people have been denied a
second referendum because boris
johnson's made it clear that he's not
prepared to do it
the scottish national party and indeed
the parliament have voted for a
referendum and have supported that
and yet it's been rejected in that
circumstance we see it as perfectly
legitimate to use the holyrood elections
as
the means of giving our people a form of
plebiscite
and that's why on the list vote they can
vote for alba which is a vote for an
independent super majority they're under
no doubt what they're looking for
exactly the same as george galloway is
putting forward a party
so as i say i think in the denial of
democracy
by a refusal of a section 30 order we've
opened up the
requirement to use the hollywood
elections as a plan b as some of my
colleagues used to talk about
but back in 2017 uh just after the
general election and the snp fought that
general election on a second referendum
uh euro there was quote no credible
platform on which to win another
referendum
and that people were tired of referenda
that was only four years ago what's
changed
well i think one of the reasons i've
gone to alba is that there has been a
lack of preparation amongst the
leadership of the snp
action does have to be taken on
discussing borders and discussing
currency and discussing pensions issues
that we knew were difficult in 2014
if issues have now transformed because
of brexit
so the groundwork has to be laid alba
will be doing that and the parliament
can ensure that
so that was a position taken with regard
to the snp
and equally it would also be fair to say
that the brexit uh
the brexit deal that has been struck is
causing mayhem in the economy in
scotland in my own constituency in
particular
the threats to our health and social
services faced by trade deals that are
coming down the line with the usa
the attacks upon our parliament through
the internal market bill
all of these things mean that the ground
has changed and now is the time for
scotland to defend itself
all right well four years ago that you
wrote the doubts on the currency and on
pensions
as two examples have not been answered
or assuaged so
in four years do you not have the answer
what currency would an independent
scotland use well we're making it clear
that we'll move towards our own currency
initially we have to use sterling that
is perfectly possible governor mark
carney acknowledged that before he
retired there won't be a currency union
that was the position taken by
george osborne but there can be use of
sterling but we'll move as soon as we
can towards the scottish currency that's
uh careful
so you would use a form of sterling
ization as it's called you wouldn't be
part of monetary union
but you would still use sterling which
you would have
no right to print or to set interest
rates then you wouldn't have a central
bank as a
bank of last resort because it wouldn't
be able to create money how long would
you be in that position
well i'd be for a shortest period of
time as as possible that's something
that has to be discussed both within our
party democracy and fundamentally by
those negotiating
but i think you know there were there
was a plan put forward by the
scottish national party through the
growth commission that was for some
considerable period of time
that is unacceptable it has to be in a
reasonable time scale it has to be
quite speedy but the precise tab i don't
think will be for me it will be for
those representing the scottish
government and speaking on behalf of the
scottish parliament
but it will have to be speedier and do
you accept
that if there was a new currency to be
launched
that you would have to pay in your
interest rates a risk premium because
this would be a new currency
with no track record for a country with
a massive budget deficit
and a balance of payments deficit you'd
have to pay a lot
to borrow wouldn't you well these
these things have been changing and
evolving there are issues and challenges
that we face exactly the same as those
issues and challenges that the united
kingdom faces
but the resources scotland faces the
position in which we are in terms of
uh being able to transition on to
independence
we are in a better position than almost
any country in the history
of being able to move out so there are
challenges but um
yesterday would move out with a deficit
about 10
of gdp it would be the highest deficit
in europe
you're proposing a new currency that
you'd have to borrow in to finance some
of that deficit i doubt you could
finance at all
so you would be paying a lot of money to
borrow to get people to lend for that
huge deficit that's not a very good
position to be
well almost every government has been
operating on a deficit other than japan
and china for many
years uh so it's nothing unusual and
indeed as i say i think the whole nature
of the
economy that we were told was impossible
of deficit
you know the whole corona virus crisis
across the world
not simply the western world has shown
that deficits are necessary can be
managed it's how you
deal with your economy at the present
moment the scottish economy is being
damaged by the brexit deal
news would be the biggest in europe what
currency would the people's pensions be
paid in
well these these things are arrangements
that are made they happen
you're across borders you're speaking to
me from out with you know the united
kingdom so it's something
unusual for people to be receiving
pensions payments or whatever else in
different countries in different
countries
my pensions paid in sterling which is
what it i always expected it to be
but what currency would an independent
scotland's pensions being
well independent scotland once you moved
into the scottish country they would be
in the scottish currency
it would be depending where you're
getting your pension i will be receiving
a pension presumably from westminster
unless arrangements are made with
with the scottish parliament and also be
receiving a pension through the scottish
civil service
so these things are dealt with by the
individual institution depending upon
their
well you could i would suggest if you
have your own currency you could only
pay
pensions in whatever that scottish
currency was and there would always be a
risk which i think it would only be fair
to make
uh knowledgeable to the scottish people
that as a new currency
uh as the new kid on the block there
would be a risk that that
currency could depreciate substantially
against sterling couldn't wouldn't there
well there are risks in every currency
as we've seen with the with the pound
sterling which uh
uh has gone up and gone down or whatever
but you know at the end of the day
but that doesn't matter for pensions uh
kenya mccaskill you know
it may go up or down but you're you're
paying for stuff
in sterling and your pensions and
sterling
you would be in a situation where you
would be paying the pensions in local
currency
and against sterling it could be
substantially devalued
but the problem with the scottish
economy at the present moment is we
don't have the levers of power
our economy is underperforming you know
i grew up in the 60s at a time when oil
was discovered in scotland and in norway
scotland has been left lagging way
behind as norway has motored on
the economy of the republic of ireland
has motored beyond not simply northern
ireland but scotland with a
higher quality of life and standard of
living that's because these countries
have been able to decide their own
future to take decisions to benefit from
their own natural assets
and so yes of course you're correct
there are issues and challenges that we
face
but equally there are opportunities
because the tragedy for scotland andrew
isn't how bad things are for the likes
of me because life's quite
good for me i have to say but tragically
it's not good for so many more scotland
should be doing so much better we are
underperforming
that's ultimately the responsibility of
westminster that has been in charge of
the economic levers of power
why are you so virtuative about
nicolas sturgeon in july 2020 you
described her as a
narcissistic sociopath uh no i didn't
in july 20 2020 you were criticized for
liking
you were liking a tweet sorry i
corrected but you liked to tweet
calling her a narcissistic sociopath
well that was a
that was a friend who had put the tweet
out it wasn't my words and i was simply
uh
uh it was in relationship to
the person i knew you like things you
don't like
well i think we all retweet things and
you know
social media has a downside i'm
currently getting a lot of
uh traffic in as you can imagine uh and
we come for that
i have to shoulder shoulder with nicola
sturgeon and with alex salmond i stood
on the platform with them together and
referendum
i disagree with actions that nicola has
taken but equally i respect the
contributions she has made when i served
in cabinet with her
and indeed her continued contribution in
the scottish government but we disagree
on various
issues and on that basis i have gone
into the alba party
you accused her of treating voters with
contempt
i don't know the context that you're
you're referring to that i mean i may
have i may have used those words but i
think you would require to tell me just
what
what the context of the article was
because it'll be one reference to
something
right well it was a reference to a
number of things that she
had been doing you accused her of the
snp had become
under her a stalinist uh
strict presbyterian sect
and that's i mean political disagreement
i can understand but this is a
uh woman who has become
you know the best-known politician in
scotland the most formidable politician
in scotland uh
who leads a government that is almost
certainly to be re-elected in me in some
form
and yet your language about her is it's
almost as if you were
talking in europe about the tories well
i think if you will recall that uh i was
out of politics for a while i was a
columnist as you yourself are and as
your colleagues are in the spectator
you use language that you wouldn't
necessarily perhaps use when you're an
elected politician
uh to describe things i as i say have
the highest respect for nicola sturgeon
i disagree
with her on how she has been running the
operation the scottish national party
it's simply unacceptable that her
husband is the chief executive i've
argued that
even you know when i was still uh an msp
uh i think there are issues and where
they've gone and women's rights that i
fundamentally disagree with and have
written about in the paper today because
i think
there are issues whether it's in unisex
toilets or the safety and security of
staff and women prisoners in the women's
prison estate
that the snp has made big mistakes on uh
but i recognize her commitment to
independence i recognize her
contribution
and that's why both alex sam and myself
and every member of alba will be
happy to stand shoulder to shoulder with
her and every other member of the snp on
the wider common cause
if there is not a majority of msps
after the election who who stood on an
independence
manifesto if there's not a majority
what then happens to a second referendum
well it's exactly the same there is a
majority it depends upon
the present moment until the snp are
prepared to change their position then
we're dependent upon
boris johnson's uh veto we think that
delivering an independence majority
changes the whole dynamic of the debate
and opens up
that i understand that and that's the
always the resurrector of alba i
understand that but if there isn't a
majority of msps for independence
after may what happens to a second
referee i believe that there will be but
uh
the position the position of alban
indeed the position i always subscribe
to in the snp andrew was that i want
independence but also
as well as independence i want scotland
to be the best it can be
so whilst you're in devolution then you
have to make sure that the scotland that
you seek
is as good as it can be and indeed if
the people of scotland were ever to
decide that they ultimately didn't want
independence then it would still be my
obligation in my home to
home country to make sure that this is
the best country that it can be
there are issues you know that we have
to address in scotland
not all of which i fully accept can be
laid at the bear of london
we have to up our game across a whole
swathe of areas
but the only people who are going to do
that the only people who will prioritize
that
are the scots and the through their
elected representatives
the turnout at scottish elections is not
that
impressive if it was under 50 percent
if turnout was below 50 percent in may
where would that leave your mandate well
i i think the mandate would still exist
because you take elections
on terms of what is delivered and it's
the outcome uh there are challenges in
this election which is
why you know postal ballots are
increasingly being pushed
even if half the scots hadn't voted that
would
undermine your mandate even if you were
to win a super majority no i'm not going
you know i'm not going to deny i want as
big a turnout as possible and equally
fair to say
that i think those in the more
challenged areas where voting is perhaps
less uh the norm are also more likely to
vote for us so there's an imperative for
us to actually try and ensure that and
we will be doing that
because i think what was clear was in
the independence referendum
the turnout was higher in that
referendum than it has been in
any uh hollywood election before or
after
uh that tends to be the situation in
referenda that do encourage huge
turnouts and wider issues
so i think that turned out here will be
substantial will be significant because
we've made this
on the constitution it's a final
question ian blackford who who leads the
snp parliamentary delegation in
westminster in the house of commons
he said of your defection that you had
become an increasing embarrassment to
the snp
and that your departure was somewhat of
a relief
as people who are united by a common
cause that doesn't
sound like solidarity to me well i think
that's uh that's what ian blackford to
comment on he made similar courtic
and caustic remarks against joanna
cherry who remains in the snp
i think that's something ian blackford
should reflect upon i'm not going to
criticize him on air i've disagreed with
them on issues but equally again as with
nicola sturgeon
on the cause of independence i will
continue to work with them as i always
have in the past
and uh i just hope that he will reflect
and learn from that
kevin mccaskill i know election
campaigns are a busy time
so we're grateful to you for giving us
your time here
on spectator tv
[Music]
you